Hi everyone, I'm Brian Krueger with CollegeGrad.com and this is the Job Search Minute.
Okay, you just had a great interview, now what?
Step number 1: Thank yous.
Request a business card from each person you meet with.
Then send out an e-mail thank you within 24 hours.
Did you forget to ask for a business card?
Call your primary contact and ask for the e-mail address...
...and correct spelling of the name of each interviewer.
Step number 2: Letters of recommendation.
If you did not provide them in the interview,...
...send them out a day or two after the interview as reinforcement of your value.
Step number 3: Follow up.
You should have asked in the interview what the next steps would be and the timing.
If you didn't, call your primary contact.
Know the timing and make sure you follow up at the appropriate time.
This has been the Job Search Minute.
For more career information, please visit CollegeGrad.com